okay so trey gowdy is one of the people
who has seen the documents he's read
them
he's also been briefed in the classified
briefing and is saying that he doesn't
have a problem with what the FBI did as
far as an informant in or in or around
the Trump campaign here's the president
last night they had people infiltrating
our campaign can you imagine it was
President Trump himself who said number
one I didn't collude with Russia but if
anyone connected with my campaign did I
want the FBI to find that out what
worries me beyond the Russians
themselves or the collusion issue but
the president's willingness to kind of
make broad-based ad hominem attacks
against the whole integrity of the FBI
so what about this and where we stand
and the Attorney General Sessions
comments all of it let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Abie Stoddard associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and guide Benson
political editor townhall.com also on
radio with Marie harf who our guest
right now is holding down the fort she
is okay your thoughts on trey Gowdy and
what this means for the investigation
well I think we have to pay very close
attention to what trey Gowdy is saying
because he has extraordinary access to
actual information about this we all
chatter about it and speculate all day
and all night
but he knows more than 99.99% of us do
because he's seen actual documents so
when he comes out and says this was an
appropriately predicated investigation
and the informant within the Trump
campaign was not a spy were acting
inappropriately in any way I think that
matters and many in the media are
seizing on that element of his interview
with Martha McCallum but the quote also
to me that sticks out he said quote it
has nothing to do with Donald Trump
himself that is significant if Gowdy is
saying if there was this informant which
there was what he was examining was not
targeting the president that matters
biron that's true I mean as that you
look at the coverage around the horn of
the second part really got chopped off
all day today
got ignored the the second part I think
there are a couple of reasons to explain
this one trey gowdy as a federal
prosecutor I think has more trust in the
Justice Department than Devin Nunez does
I think it's pretty clear there but I
knew we should point out that we haven't
heard from Devin Nunez he was out and
about and talking a lot until that
briefing and he has not talked about the
briefing there are other people who are
in the briefing who have not talked
about it as well he is not the only one
but I think the important thing to
remember is the house was trying to get
documents about this informant they were
trying to say for example did the
informant issue give reports to the
Justice Department if the important that
the informant talked to George
papadopolis did you write it up did he
give it to the Justice Department the
fact is they haven't seen that stuff yet
so the Justice Department can say we
followed all the rules everything's
great don't worry about it we did it by
the book but the house hasn't seen the
stuff yet
the other question is if the
president-elect is getting classified
briefings as president-elect why is he
not in the loop if it had nothing to do
with President Trump why is he not told
what the informant is trying to do about
finding any Russian connection in those
briefings one would think that he had
briefings along the way he was briefed
the Hillary Clinton campaign was briefed
they were told that this was happening
and that this look that people are
questioning Trey Gowdy's are there
imputing his integrity his his motive
here today and I'm not no no no but I'm
talking about his critics here I'm
talking about people calling him the
phony saying he's covering up for a
corrupt FBI because in the fever swamps
and in tribal battle people want to
paint this like he's a secret Loretta
Lynch Hillary Clinton Obama partisan
fighting to cover up a corrupt FBI he is
doing this because he knows that what
President Trump is doing is what Senator
Warner describes he's launching an
assault on the intelligence community
and the law enforcement agencies that we
depend on in this country and he's doing
it knowingly what is Rudy Giuliani
running around telling reporters in town
the president thinks this is working
he's branded at Spygate
it's working it this is a campaign to
discredit Bob Muller's findings
nothing else Trump knows there was no
spy infiltrating his campaign he knows
that it wasn't him that they were after
that they were checking out Russians
that were trying to get into his
campaign and connect with his campaign
but he's doing it anyway okay here you
mentioned senator Warner here's
something else and a Warner said about
the investigation overall people have
kind of got exhaustion from the
day-to-day back-and-forth of this story
I think the American public will be will
be tired of it if this is not wound down
in this calendar year yeah I think
that's significant he's part of the
Intelligence Committee that was looking
into this who was really aggressive at
the beginning and seems to be kind of
saying we got to wrap this thing up by
the end of 2018 whether it's before the
midterms are or after basically echoing
the vice president from a few weeks ago
urging robert muller to get this thing
finished up soon and i think it makes
sense on some level investigations don't
need to be unending and forever which
seems to be the standard that some Trump
critics want in this case it's a cloud
that continues to hang over him if the
point is to prevent the Russians and
other hostile powers from influencing
our elections again in the future as
they attempted to do in 2016 it would be
nice to know what happened before the
next election
so what Warner said there I think you're
right is significant a Democrat saying
okay let's go the other story obviously
the New York Times had this story not a
surprise to some people that the
president may have said why don't you
get back in the game to attorney General
Sessions on his recusal here is the
president on tape and also trey Gowdy
weighing in on this he was going to he
should have told me before he took the
job and I would have picked somebody
else if I were the president and I
picked someone to be the country's chief
law enforcement officer and they told me
later oh by the way I'm not going to be
able to participate in the most
important case in the office I would be
frustrated to burn I think the the sound
you played from the president was from
July of last year he still
mad about it I mean he's always going to
be to be mad about it because he
believes that the grounds that sessions
used to recuse himself were knowable
before sessions was even appointed
attorney general and I think when trey
gowdy said hey maybe the the sessions
could have said wait a minute I'll have
to recuse myself from this extremely
important case president is clearly
still mad about it but frustrated
because the chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee who would be
responsible for confirming a successor
as Attorney General has basically said
that the White House I think we're busy
I don't think we can confirm another
Attorney General